foreign
[Music]
19 20 21 22 23 24 oh shoot all right I'm
gonna try and get to 50. at some point
on this stream that would be sweet
what's up everybody welcome back this is
the final stream of the Endless engines
3D challenge working streamer of course
we have a live judging stream
uh two weeks from now I believe
um
on the 18th but welcome welcome everyone
thanks for hanging out with me we're
gonna be chilling today guys we are
hanging out having a good time I'm gonna
be making so I'll get into it uh story
wise and figure out I'll got some
explaining to do but basically I'm gonna
be making a piece of art throughout this
this stream with you guys I'm putting
together like an intro title sequence
for this awesome car Montage vehicle
Montage that we got coming out pretty
soon here
so I'm gonna try and get through that
um in c4d on the stream make a cool
piece of art with you guys and any
questions you'll have to my to all those
artists out there working on this
challenge
I got you any questions I know the
submission date is coming up that's
going to be let's see March 12th at 11
P.M
PST it says am should be pm
um anyway
I'm a little winded from that hacky sack
man that hacky sack gets you
it's good though it's a great workout
what's up everybody thanks for joining
thanks for hopping in who do we got
right now who's who's hanging out with
us
um well of course we got the moderators
up in the chat right now so thank you
guys uh Ronan visual I see you
sotomontay always uh behind the scenes
where soda where you at somewhere
floating
hello hello oh there he is what's up
Soto
um
so guys it's gonna be awesome we're
gonna hop right into it
um so any questions y'all have in terms
of submissions in terms of wrapping out
your renders
um I'm here for you guys the next two
hours we're gonna be hanging out we'll
be answering any questions you guys have
um and
yeah I just want to make it as easy as
possible so far guys we have
648 submissions
um for this challenge with about a week
left a little over a week left
um in this Challenge and that is those
are some good numbers I'm very excited
to see what you guys put together
obviously you saw at the beginning of
this thing we got uh some sweet renders
uh from the community so yeah I can't
wait to see what you guys do I'm gonna
be shouting out people
um
anyone who submits I'll be shouting them
out here
if you're ready to submit don't don't
submit prematurely you know that that is
not not a good move but I'll be shouting
out people who submit uh live here
and any time
one of y'all Super Chat I think I'll uh
kick around this hacky sack a little bit
and see if we can't get to 50.
so that's my goal
um on this stream gotta gotta keep
active you know gotta keep the joints
oiled and whatnot
um so
let's hop in let's create some art let's
hang out and have a good time
where we at where are we at boom here we
go
[Music]
all right so
like I said I got some explaining to do
I'll be honest with y'all I straight up
ran out of time
um I
you know I was too far in without having
started a submission and I was like you
know what
this is not gonna go this is not gonna
go well
this is not going to go well whatsoever
so what I'm doing this time around is
I'm actually going to be making an intro
title sequence with credits and like
cool graphics and all this and they're
all related to uh you know you know
racing stuff I guess
um so I got like a road whipping by with
some really cool surface imperfections
on the road I got like a tire with the
camera locked off on it and it's like
spinning
all cool
um with the camera locked off so I'm
super excited to to
you know to finish that intro title
sequence but I'm also going to complete
a shot here okay as far as I can
um with you guys
uh hear all the streams so I have an
idea for a shot basically where where
imagine you're in a tunnel
and the tile that makes up the wall of
the tunnel is very reflective and the
camera is essentially locked to the car
and you can see the reflection of the
car in the tile so it's like very
abstract you know but
um still gives you that sense of speed
gives you that motion and will be great
for an intro title sequence
um for this challenge right so we got
the music being worked on right now
Casey Edwards is crushing the music
um it's it sounded freaking amazing
so let's jump in if you guys have
questions for me regarding submission
regarding the challenge in general just
at me here in this in this live chat all
right uh at ponisher that way I can see
it a little bit better I'll do my best
to keep up with the chat here and then
like I said any super chats that go down
um I'll I'll bust out the hacky sack and
try and get to 50. we'll see
we'll have the personal personal best
record
um in the chat here so let's freaking
jump into it I what do I want to do so
24 FPS that's the first thing control D
in c4d will get you to your project
settings and I'll set that to 24. I'm
also going to go up to my render
settings
um I've pinned these or no these
actually are here
um in the newest c4d updates so I'm
gonna grab this guy render settings
we'll go to Output
um 1920 by 810 is what we're doing this
time around for the challenge and the
frame rate you need to change that as
well 24 and we're gonna do all frames
I'll set this to Octane because I'm
using octane
I'm also using Aces as well which is
like a nice little color space so I'm
going to walk you guys through that in
my art breakdown later but basically
I'll do it right now so I'm gonna switch
this to
ldr I believe let's see let me figure
out
switches to Ocio
grab the output
output srgb
and I believe if I go to Octane render
settings
and we go to Ocio we'll set this to Aces
srgb and then that will have us up in
Aces
um
visual was doing his rendering Aces and
he actually inspired me to do the same
it's about time I figured that out
there's a nice tutorial online it's like
aces in five minutes it's real quick in
case you set up and everything so I
think we're good to go we can test it
out I'm gonna bust out my live viewer
let's just hit
render and let's get something in here
Cube sure
let me pin this for you guys
bam and if I make a camera we hop into
it and we go to the camera imager if I
check the camera imager and try and
adjust the gamma it shouldn't change
okay so it is I just need to go down to
Ocio srgb and we're locked in we're
running in Aces now so that's good we
can do some before and after comparisons
of course let's save our scene
um and call this tile V1
sweet we're set up to start creating I
always bust out a figure for scale
always always bust out a figure for
scale then you kind of know what what
skill you're working with but let's go
ahead and check out any of these
questions that you guys have
um Ronan thank you
visual thank you thank you guys for
for answering these questions here in
this chat let's go through is if I use a
freeze frame
um I had I don't know I don't know
uh that's an artistic Choice there it
depends can I mess with focal length
not really the focal length is pretty
locked
um unless you're trying to do a very
like quick little like like little Zoom
thing but
I don't know even then that's it's an
artistic
um
that's an artistic choice
technically not really allowed but if
you find out a way to do it and stay
within the rules then yeah that's good
um let's see thanks for this opportunity
uh I'd be using a jet pack on the back
of my character here your rules were to
keep the engine on focus is it gonna
work or not
um
well as long as the character is Center
focused and is the focus of the scene
then I think it'll be fine
uh Riley how much are we allowed to mess
with the camera thinking about adding
camera shake and a little whip pan at
the beginning Riley so that one is
definitely an FAQs but that's okay we're
here to answer all questions
uh camera Shake is absolutely allowed
you know absolutely it's gonna I think
make these renders look a little bit
better
I would think
um
see a whip pan you know that's
that's kind of up to you technically the
submission or the project file was built
in a way that all the renders flow into
and out of each other adding a wet pan
might switch that up a little bit so
again that's a very that that's an
artistic choice on your end that is a
creative risk but you know that that
one's up to you
oh we got a Super Chat Austin it's hacky
sack time let's see I love your render
challenges so much I've learned blender
completely because of these thank you so
much dude that's what's up yes that is
what these things are for
um it's to get together is to have fun
and learn these programs through these
fun challenges thank you you've
unleashed to the hacky sack let's see if
we can get
see if we can beat 29 I think I got 29
last time let's see what we did we could
do
it might just be like
be like we'll see
brutal brutal
brutal seven got seven
yikes yikes are only
um but Austin thank you thank you for
that man I gotta move my bones around a
little bit it helps me with these
streams keeps my brain juices flowing
um Matt s does the vehicle have to exit
to the right or in any direction off
screen where it keeps the motion well
technically going off to the right is
kind of like the default you're going to
be safe going that way
um you know I if you're trying to exit
up exit down
I don't know I guess that depends on
your your render and
you know if you can make it work if you
can if it can blend into the other uh
renders if it can blend into the other
like little test project
um test renders that I made in the
latest project file
uh folder then yeah you can do it I
guess
um for those of you who don't know we'll
probably most of you guys know at this
point
in the description we got some links we
got um stickers I'm selling uh endless
engines limited edition stickers uh it's
a sticker sheet actually let me see I
have one right here
uh
yeah this is what it's gonna come like
boom little sticker sheet you got you
some stickers here A bunch of options
it'll give you guys a chance to put them
on whatever you want you know you don't
have to worry about just one sticker you
got like 11 stickers
um so that is in the description as well
help support these challenges
um what else we have the submission link
as well in the description for you guys
let's see if anyone's submitted in the
time we started this thing
we have four submissions
oh my goodness we got John
we got DWI Benjamin and Ryan Smith shout
outs to you guys for submitting
um hopefully those were your final
renders hopefully you're not submitting
just because I'm shouting you out
um
but congratulations nonetheless for
getting this far we're crossing that
Finish Line good stuff good stuff
um and finally for those of you who are
looking for a mega challenge I got the
starter files also linked in the
description so you can get started on
that if you want
um sort of Monday I noticed you switched
over for me when I was playing hacky
sack that's very kind of you
what a move
all right
[Applause]
moving on oh my goodness we got another
we got another Super Chat we gotta get
back at it
um okay but GS asks while keeping why
can I make cam look left or up and down
um
not really you gotta keep the camera
pretty darn locked
um in terms of the angle
um of course you can have camera shake
and whatnot
but uh
yeah this isn't like a free like you
can't just grab the camera look behind
you at something like no like your focus
is on the center car but
or Center vehicle rather it's Hacky Sack
Time
let's get it
13 all right 13 13 is not bad
13's better than seven so thank you GS
we got 13. we're gonna try and get to
50. see what we can do
um
all right it's Louvre so it's been
watching since Corridor I've been
watching every single Community
challenge along the way that's great
happy to say I'll have my own render to
throw in the pot this time yes yes yes
thank you it's so nice to see first time
um
well not first time artists but just any
anytime someone's like yeah this is my
first challenge that makes me so happy
um so keep it up it's a it's a good time
it's definitely a win it's hard to to
get through the finish line for sure so
yeah good stuff guys
all right let's get back to the art for
just a little bit here shall we
I'm gonna try and set up
a wall all I need is a wall so let's
bust out like a plane
hit r or rotate holding shift to snap
every five degrees I'm gonna bring this
back
and I'm just gonna make
a basic wall okay
and we're going to be
this needs to be quite a large wall
because we're gonna
start from one side
and animate a camera to the other side
okay
and let's go ahead and make like a
ground plane
this will be our street
[Music]
in fact I can just
duplicate This Plane
and let's get rid of this for now we
don't need that for now
all right this is our street
and then the next thing I'm gonna do is
just make these tiles so
let's go ahead
and say the tile is probably this big
it's always why I like busting out a
figure because I know the scale of my
scene
let's say that is our tile and we can go
ahead and give it a little bit
of a little fillet on that edge there
this will stand in for us we'll see what
this does and what we'll do here is let
me duplicate This Plane again
I'll hold Ctrl to duplicate it I'm just
going to move it back
n b if you hit n and B that'll change
your shading method so you can go to
display and see these shortcuts up here
and B right
um
now let's see
what I want to do is clone this Cube
across the plane here so I'm gonna grab
the cube I'm just going to rename this
to tile and I'm going to hold alt and
that'll bust out the cloner it'll
automatically put it as a child of the
Clone arm you hold Alt
and let's grab this cloner let's mess
with some settings here so first
let's bring these down
just so we can kind of see what we're
doing we just want X and Y we don't want
any forward
okay so yeah we want to go there
we're gonna go one there
awesome awesome and I think we can do
this as yeah per step
so let's just say this is five and five
foreign
there we go
amazing
okay
so here
um what we'll do is let's just get this
going
to really get this going you can see
it's starting to chug right I wonder if
I change it to render instance
it's faster now okay cool
so we'll get these tiles laid out on
this wall and we'll see how far we need
to go with it we can push these back
up against oh you know what I'm doing
this totally works this this totally
works I had another way to do it in my
mind but this
absolutely works
let's go to our side view and just push
it up against this wall
boom
you could probably make this work with
the texture
and then let's set the multi-instance
see if that goes any faster
cool all right we're going to randomize
these we're going to set up our camera
in a second but let's um let's hit this
Super Chat let's get some hacky sack in
here
so we got one from XD
um AC Clint
would be great to the addition of the AC
Empire see here's the thing
you can't take sides you know I can't
here's what I'll do I'll take them all
I'll have them all
um
but I love that the AC thing is a thing
I'm very it makes me happy I love that
people are finding their their friend
groups and you know they're building it
up so I think that's super cool
so shout outs to you XD
acxd perhaps but it's hacky sack time
anytime we're doing super chess it's
hacky sack time we're gonna try and get
to 50. I think right now we're at 13 as
our is our best so uh let's go
that's 10.
20.
20 30.
32 technically this is still live
because it's on my desk but I'm gonna
call it there 32 that's a good number 32
ain't gonna forget it
do I need to write it down and now we'll
remember 32. that was a good one that
was a good one
sweet
amazing
oh we got another Super Chat we're right
back at it thank you um not alyriza
says I wanted to add my own vehicle and
join the challenge but the thing I had
in mind was way too ambitious and wasn't
sure if we could uh could use bot assets
good luck everyone keep up the good work
Clint thank you for the support much
appreciated
um in terms of like where you're at yes
I understand
going for something that's way too
ambitious
um I'm plagued by it constantly
um it can really suck the fun out of
things when it gets too crunchy that way
so it's nice to come up with ideas that
of course you can uh
you pull off you know you want to come
up with some stuff you can pull off and
that's that's sometimes harder
than um than just saying it so I
understand also you could definitely had
used bot assets that's okay
it's okay all that stuff is in the FAQs
for the future
we think about these things we really
think about these things you know we've
done this is a challenge
Dennis five six at this point
um
so we really try and think of all the
different questions you guys would have
and put them in FAQs for you guys on the
Discord side of things but since you
super chatted let's get back to it let's
see if we can be 32.
oh
that's 10.
it's 20.
20 23 I think
it's good it's good
oh boy now I got kickball after this too
I'll be warmed up and ready
all right back to the art
I like this hacky sack breaks man that's
where it's at
all right so as this was my first idea
to do this tile situation like this was
was my first idea and we'll see how far
we can get with it
um because I'm like is it better to just
download assets
um in terms of like uh like Mega scans
tile material or something we'll see
let's let's see how far we can take this
setup right now camera wise I want it
just straight on with this thing so I'm
gonna
zero out these settings
and then I'm gonna go ahead and throw a
rigging tag a protection tag on the
camera
but give myself X Y and Z position
so I can still move around I just can't
rotate the camera so it will always be
locked off on these tiles you know what
I'm saying
um let's go ahead and
find our frame we're gonna we're gonna
have quite a lot of setup to do
because let me merge this
with the car we have so let me set up
the
I have this tire shot that I was working
on I'm still not done with it but it's
like
intense right it's like whoa with motion
blur and everything it's gonna be
amazing
um
but I'm gonna take the car
that I just downloaded for free off of
CG Trader
let's grab this car
and we want the wheel
together
boom and let's see let's even grab the
road that I set up as well
let's grab all that
and drop it in here
all right and we're gonna flip this
around
foreign
will toggle textures on or off in the
viewport
so I'm gonna get rid of those for a
second
and we can delete our fake Road
and we have
this car with the wheel
let's go ahead and open that up and uh
maybe grab the road
[Music]
and Scoot it up to the tile
this is kind of tricky this is kind of a
tricky
shot I'm trying to set up here where
we see the reflection of the car in the
tile
okay we can delete our figure
okay I'm gonna put the wheel in the car
and just gonna name my stuff
[Applause]
foreign
let's hop into the camera
and let's
bust out our octane live viewer
render this guy
and let's go ahead and set this to path
tracing
and I'm gonna go ahead and lock the
frame and scale it like zoom out just a
little bit 0.8 so we can see the whole
thing
cool
all right so this is our frame um and if
it's easier for you if you guys are in
C40 you can hit shift V and that's going
to bring up
your viewport settings and I'll go to
save frames and turn the opacity all the
way up so we can get a really good idea
of what is in our frame and
let's go ahead and add shift two is
going to bring up our our materials I'm
gonna make a new one
let's see let's make a glossy material
and I'm gonna drop it on
the tile here okay
and
I'm just gonna make it a mirror
and we'll see what we can see
you are you are evil why would you why
would you do such a thing how many in a
row can you do with just one leg okay
let's see how it is
let's see how it is sodomonte
this one's for you one leg is all we got
good look
three okay but
it landed in the singing bowl so that's
that's a little magic magic points for
sure bonus points
[Music]
I'll do it one more time I'll do it one
more time
I don't know six
there's your answer that was pretty good
that was pretty good I don't know I
could do better I could do better
but it's all good it's all good it's all
good it's all good
foreign
moving on
all right so we want to take this index
to one and that's going to make these
things chromed out all right and it's
giving this reflection
why is it acting this way
it's like mini versions of
what if I put it on the cloner
wow that is not reflecting in the way I
thought it would be reflecting
what if I take
the filet off
okay that's what I was imagining
so I'm taking I think it's like some
weird thong setting or something it's
just not
but it doesn't even
let's see it's because the smooth
shading is surrounding the whole yeah
so it's kind of like yeah
long here we go
[Music]
yep
so I want a little bit of like
I think it's just gonna like toggle on
at one point yeah
yeah okay this is what I want though
this is what I'm going for
um okay so now what we need to do is we
need to move
the car
um let's go ahead and I want to leave my
octane viewport like this down here but
I want to be able to like hop out of my
camera and maneuver here to be able to
adjust the car around so to do that I'm
essentially going to in my live viewer
we'll go to options update check and
uncheck camera that way we can hop out
of the camera in our viewport and then
still make changes live
so
I don't know something like this would
be cool
and
we're gonna move the camera and the car
mostly together
so what I'll do is I'll pop the car and
the camera
uh into a null with alt G
and slash car
and I'm gonna animate this over time so
let's see um
I don't know 20 this is 24 frames a
second times how many seconds do we want
let's say like 10 seconds
and I can always Loop these right
that's the idea would be able to to Loop
these so maybe we go 24 times
I don't know eight seconds
and we see where that gets us
um another thing I want to do for
optimization is lower the amount of
tiles that we're seeing I only want the
strip
that we're actually seeing in the camera
so basically what I'll do is bring this
to Center like this
and then just open it up a little bit
and be like that's
all we need right we want to maximize
as much as possible I'm gonna throw
let's see let's make a new
actually I'm gonna yeah let's make a new
material
just a black material
[Music]
and I'm gonna drop this on the wall
behind
yeah okay
wait what
just happened
there we go
okay
um
from here
let's go ahead and get let's let's start
a little basic animation oh we're gonna
start off an animation in a second but
first we got some hacky sacking to do
not even a message all right just a
straight up
let's go all right uh mebi man
let's see if we can beat 32 32 is where
we're at
11 12 13.
17 18 19 20.
oh
that's 28 it hit the Lego bonsai tree
but we got to 28. that's good
consistently getting above 20. you know
you're in a good place then
heart rate's up feeling alive
hanging out good renders
Good Times
thank you mebi man
much appreciated
thanks for the support
good stuff let's let's hit you guys up
any questions you're asking I know the
moderators are are helping you guys out
um but let's go up and and see these at
punishers here and see if you have any
questions how do you color grade as a
colorblind VFX artist any tips and
tricks I've been struggling to get a
good look for my Batmobile but it's hard
due to my other my own color blindness
Okay so
yes I am colorblind
and it definitely is like
a spectrum of like like no one's seeing
in black and white as far as I know
um but like for me it's like red green
gets a bit tricky Brown's like a bit
tricky
um it's hard to tell some like violets
and whatnot I get them a little confused
with other colors a lot of colors will
look the same and it's hard for me to
tell like what that color really is so I
think the first thing is like
I always go
to just what looks good to my eye what
looks great
um and nine times out of ten it'll be
it'll be okay like that
that will actually work it doesn't
affect me too too much
um but like I said it is a spectrum so
um one thing that helps me when I'm in a
pinch sometimes
um is of course looking at your your
Scopes you're you're like the vector
Scopes when you're color correcting and
you can look and see like you know are
my oranges too maxed out my skin tones I
look like you know like an Oompa Loompa
or something it's like we'll bring that
down you can bring that down and you can
judge that by looking at your vector
Scopes
um in uh in DaVinci or Premiere right
it's a pretty basic thing that all color
correcting software has
um is like a
there's like a view to to look at the
actual data and the numbers of your
colors so that's one way another way
like when I'm trying when I'm
compositing and I'm trying to like
um say for instance I'm trying to take a
3D object and composite it into live
action footage and you gotta like tweak
them colors you got to get it right it's
really hard like
the best way when I get stuck in that
situation is to
um color correct in black and white mode
so I'll essentially just lock it to the
red Channel and it turns black and white
and then you work your sliders to
essentially have it fit in this black
and white view so you just make sure
your values match right your black and
white values and then you go to Blue and
it'll switch it to like a different
looking black and white View and you
adjust it that way get your Black and
Whites looking nice
green same thing and then when you
switch back it should look great
actually
um and then you might need to tweak a
little bit and then of course ask a
friend if someone's nearby like hey does
this look
does this look right
um
and that's always that's always a good
thing so ask for help look at your
Scopes
um and work in black and white to get
your your values locked in those are
some things that I do
when it when it when it uh when I need
to usually it's just by my eye you know
at this point I'm just doing my thing
but
good question very good question
um
let's see riffs and coffee I see you
give me two seconds Catch My Breath here
on my answer one or two more questions
um
is it okay to have a vehicle teleport
between two environments that means the
car will appear and exit twice in the
scene
um yeah I've seen some teleportation
renders you know
um
I think generally it's okay as long as
the car is in frame for most of the
you know the render then you're good
it's subtle lens absorption okay totally
yeah totally fine
um are we allowed to use people filmed
in front of green screen as cards yeah
that's great nice little hack good
little cheat there
um
let's see
what is my way of critiquing anime
renders well the same way I'd critique
any other render which would just be you
know how's your lighting how's your
composition what's your idea look like
um
uh like your concept your story right
uh did you follow the rules
how is your color the lighting you know
all these things I'm I'm taking into
account how well does it look how nice
does it look and then I go deeper like
is there a story to it so it's the same
way I'm critiquing all of these
different submissions across the board
I'm not doing like anime submissions
differently or anything
we got
we got some super jets
um can you mess with the camera f-stop
um
yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely
absolutely
um and you would do that of course to
allow for
um like a deeper depth of field or if
you're talking like actual cameras to
brighten or darken your scene it opens
up the iris or closes it down
but um let's start with riffs and coffee
thank you very much for that Super Chat
very generous of you you submitted
earlier today and it's your first go at
trying these challenges just wanted to
say the community and support has been
incredible so thank you for bringing
everyone together dude that is very
great for me to hear we've worked very
hard on building this community on doing
these challenges and having the
community be a supportive place
is and hearing that from you that is
that is great to hear honestly because
you know we wouldn't want the opposite
they don't be a toxic community of
course not I want to be a place where
people are chilling hanging out
supporting each other
um sharing tips and tricks and just
being cool being chill so that's what I
want to do
um and it seems that all you guys have
done the same so thank you so much to
the community for
we're holding it down
um and being super chill and resting
coffee
it's hacky sack time let's see if we can
beat 32.
um I think 23 is what we got last time
that's 10.
20.
30.
40.
dude almost lost it there that's 41
though that's a new record yeah
heck yeah
oh I love I love hacky sack I Can't Get
Enough
um but maybe man
my goodness I see you I see you
um we got another one we got another
round just for you thank you that was
very generous of you thank you thank you
very much
41 okay let's see if we can beat
41.
that's 25 6 27.
28.
28 is not bad
I'll take 28 any day
thank you for the support you guys are
awesome
any other questions to see and then
we'll get back to the art
um does the higher resolution matter in
getting top three not at all no not at
all
um you know I want the final video to be
in 4k in fact it will be in 4k even if
it's all 1080 renders I'm gonna scale it
up to 4K
because
my intro
renders will be in 4k and I want them to
be in 4k
so the more 4K renders the better but
that's okay it's not it doesn't have
anything to do with judging
um as long as you guys do 1920x810
it's either that or it's um
3840 by 16 20.
are sound effects necessary for the
video absolutely not you don't have to
do any sound effects because I won't be
using them it's just going to be music
you can add sound effects for yourself
but if you're like I have a day left and
I have to do sound effects like no you
don't have to do sound effects all good
how slow or fast can the vehicle be it
can be any speed as long as the sense of
speed is captured that is it
um Casey what's up Casey
yeah um Casey's crushing the music right
now he's enjoying your guys's renders
I've been sending them like uh the
highlights some of my favorite ones you
guys have submitted so far
to help him with the music so that's
cool what up Casey I mean you probably
figured out this point but we're doing
some hacky sack on the stream today
I think we're at 41 is the record right
now
epoxo what's up dude
you man
good to see you I wonder are you working
on the submissions time around are you
just chilling
I know you go all in with your stuff man
super cool
um all right last question is it okay if
half the vehicle is still visible on the
120th frame it's not a train it's a car
yeah that's cool man that's cool as long
as it starts its exit
um
how uh as long as it starts to exit
like the template scene starts its exit
like timing wise on frame whatever then
you'll you'll be good
how many submissions we got we got oh we
got a couple more we got four more we
got Aaron easel Florham homdo Hondo
Skiller and Dennis spap
with you guys congratulations for
submitting that's huge definitely take
this as a win kick back relax enjoy
yourself yeah let's get back to the art
let's get back to the art
okay
um
oh man we got another Super Chat though
real quick real quick
real quick uh real vjy
I see you and we're gonna do this this
one's for you okay all right
41.
foreign
but thank you
okay
gosh
all right here's what I want to do I
want to animate this thing so we're
going to take this Cam and car
null object frame zero to make
you know let's do auto keyframe let's go
to the end
of
this
black wall here
and that should be locked in now this is
not updating because I do need to in
fact update this camera and then
hop into it and then we should be seeing
yep
it's a movement here and of course we
lose the tile
after a minute so let's extend it
cloner
boom
pop in
[Music]
oh man
I see what happened
let me undo that real quick I just
stretched out the wrong piece
I want to add 8 22.
let's go 900.
thousand
oh
all right
but here's the here's the thing here's
what's gonna make it awesome is we take
this and we
I might be getting a little ahead of
myself but with the cloner selected we
can go ahead and grab a random effector
and this is really gonna make the tiles
seem a bit more worn down we'll go to
the parameter and position I don't want
to mess with position it's rotation that
I want to mess with so let's check
rotation and let's give all of these
like two degrees of Randomness and that
is already too much so we can try point
two
and that's super cool yeah it breaks it
up in a fun way I like that a lot and
what we can do also is
we can take this camera we can
zoom in just a little bit let's take it
at like a 50 I don't know maybe a 45
that's cool and let's go to the camera
tag and add some depth of field so I'm
going to take the let's see where is it
depth of field yeah aperture let's try
that too
yes yes three
so it's real out of focus and then I'm
going to take this is to make it look
anamorphic right so anamorphic means
um
basically at the end result is it looks
more filmic
um the bokeh blown out uh lights in the
background are stretched vertically
um and that comes from I believe the
camera
um or the lens it's the lens the lenses
are anamorphic and uh what it does is I
believe
it shoots it like
either super wide and you have to
scrunch it down which scrunches the
depth of field it scrunches those like
bokeh bits so we're gonna simulate we're
just gonna like not simulate that but
recreate it and of course the focus is
on the tile
it'll be on this grungy tile
but then you get this like
blurry kind of abstract Motion in the
background like we can set that to six
and it gets all crazy right but I think
for now three is good we're starting to
get the effect we're going for we can
take the random effect or two and like
maybe we can push that a little further
to make it a bit more abstract
heck we can we can go one with it so
it's like
crazy looking right and then each frame
is going to be some insane looking thing
and then of course when we add motion
blur this is all the spice on top that
really makes this come together we're
gonna get back to the lighting and
whatnot but let's add motion blur we've
got a motion blur tab
um I set this to centered so the shutter
alignment is centered meaning like the
blur isn't happening back here it's not
happening up here it's happening right
here in the middle
um
and I always go as default I always go
half of my or double my frame rate so my
frame rate is 24 so I'm gonna go one
over 48 so I'm literally going to type 1
divided by 48 1 over 48. hit enter and
it's not working because we need to
check motion blur and there you go
that looks super cool
it's awesome so now the
the detail really comes in with the
lighting and the the the texturing of
these pieces of tile okay
um
so let us
mess with some lighting all right so I
think the first thing I'm gonna do
let's try
a strip of light
above this car okay
um I want to let's just go ahead and
make a hdri background
like this
so this is just darkness this is just
black
right
and it looks like
super abstract which is cool I like that
I like that but it's too much right it's
too much so what we'll do let's take
this
octane sky and it's set to just well
it's a color let's set it to a color
just darkness right because we're going
to light it with our own stuff and
um let's go ahead and grab a area light
now I'll bring it above the car
I'm going to rotate this so it's
pointing down at the car
like this
mm-hmm
[Music]
and let's skinny it up
stretch it way out
turn it to like a a nasty
like green color
um so texture I believe
and then we'll use a light color
where is that controlled from
trolled from
should be a way to get into here we go
node View
bam
uh we can just do like an RGB
texture
RGB Spectrum pop that into texture
and we can change this to like
you know some green nasty green color
just to make sure it's working
see
it's not working
let me uncheck use color there we go
there we go that's so backwards
um
yeah let's get that nasty green coming
back
just subtle yeah there we go there we go
cool make sure you guys save your scene
so it's reflecting nothing like we got
Darkness back here so technically what
we can do I'm gonna go ahead and
download let's go to quixel bridge
and let me sign in real quick
yeah I think we're good
um let's go to 3D let's go to surfaces
um I know there's some tile up in here
tile yeah
and we want ceramic
yep
like this kind of stuff right so we
might even be able to use some of these
instead of uh swimming pool tiles this
is pretty much what I'm going for
4K is fine let's go ahead and download
this
[Music]
this is probably the way to do it
honestly because it'll export it right
it's going to pop into our scene I'm
gonna grab a few of these because I want
to work quick right so
I'm gonna look at these and see maybe
old ceramic tiles that's pretty cool I
like how they have uh
some of them are popping out some of
them are sunken in all that stuff is
kind of already built in
so I'm gonna work through this here
[Music]
epoxy says remember that stretching the
light that much will make it much more
diffuse than several smaller ones if
that's what you're looking for thank you
Hawk so I appreciate that we'll get back
to it I'm just kind of like roping it
all in you know oh this black and white
one is interesting
let's download this one
export that I definitely want to go for
a grungier look
but
it's definitely cool to have the option
[Music]
old swimming pool tiles
let's download that
[Music]
and export
I'm thinking of this very specific
tunnel in downtown L.A
I actually shot
a short there let's see
I'll pull it up here
so it's this tunnel it's this tunnel you
see how reflective this stuff is super
crisp right and of course I color
corrected it to
be pretty darn green but I think it was
naturally green anyway but you can see
there's lots of like little little
details here
um
it's pretty darn compressed
but
you know there's different patches in
the wall
um yeah it's lit from all these little
dots all these little dotted bits of
light up in here
um
let's see
yeah all these patches and stuff so I
think I'll probably work some of that in
as well to help vary it but you can see
how that's all these little tiles and
whatnot right
yeah you guys remember this one
for sure
it's a good one
as one of my favorites absolutely one of
my favorites all right Will Clark I see
you
I've been waiting to get some hacky sack
in let's take a look so Will Clark you
said this was your first Challenge and
sent in your submission last week yes
congratulations
um you had a blast and learned a ton in
ue5 dude that's what's up I know it's a
pretty scary program for people but you
just need a fun project to dive in and
learn the program with and you know
you'll hear me say the time time again
that's what these challenges are for
um definitely not top 100 level but
still super fun
dude congratulations the fact that you
got through the process and delivered
your art means the most you should be
super proud of that take that uh with
you as long as you can you know who
cares about top 100 I know I know this
is It's a thing I know a lot of you are
guys are going for that but I think just
the fact that
you finish something that says so much
all right so you guys should all be very
very proud of submitting Will Clark
congratulations
um this one is for you
all right we're gonna see if we can beat
41.
we're gonna see if we can do it
[Music]
20.
oh no
I have to get I have to get that it went
behind the piano
foreign
remember what I got
oh like 28 or something
Good Times
I play a little bit piano a little bit
of piano my wife plays a little bit
better than me she can sight read pretty
well
but I mess around a little bit I mess
around
okay back to it
zelly Max is right
March 12th
absolutely March 12th is the deadline
Good Times all around ooh dirty ceramic
wall tile yes please download
we're gonna make these real shiny guys
real shiny
so here's what
we are gonna do all right let me hide
this light
let me hide
the
this guy okay
um
let's get rid of our tiles and our
cloner all right we had a good time we
had a good time but it wasn't the move
I am going to make
um let me try
Cube
stretch this out
bear with me here I'm gonna make a
little tunnel
stretch this out scale it
up
this will save us on like render time
and
performance in our viewport all that
good stuff okay
and we're gonna
make this editable by hitting C I'm
gonna go ahead and get rid of the back
piece
the floor
the other back piece
and I'm essentially going to grab these
two edges
and bevel them
[Music]
right okay but we want like 10
subdivisions
and we're just going to bring that
all the way
until they touch
and that's our little tunnel system here
cool let's go ahead and scale that down
just a bit
and
and move our road over
so that it's right in line with this
thing
cool
tunnel great and let's go ahead and grab
some of these uh
some of these little bits here
um let's start with
[Music]
dirty ceramic wall let's put that on
there and see what we can see now it's
stretched out like crazy let's go ahead
and bring our light back in so we can
see what we're doing let's hop into our
camera
and we see we don't have we need to kind
of get back to uh seeing our car we need
to get back to those tiles so right now
the projection is way off I'm gonna hop
into this thing
let's hop in
and
first things first let's clean things up
I think if we can grab all these and
then hit
Auto arrange selected that helps a
little bit
all right so we have our displacement
that'll come in handy for sure
um we have roughness
which is going into a color correction
node
okay we have
ambient occlusion with our color pass
and a transform so what I'm going to do
is grab all of the
let's grab all of these textures
right click and go to add selected
projection and I'll pipe them all in as
projection node
and we will set them to box maybe
[Music]
but it still looks pretty Darn stretched
out doesn't it so let's take the
transform and let's hit the scale
oh man what am I even looking at
I'm going to render region
your region
set this back to one
[Music]
I'm just trying to find the natural like
Square
I can't find it where is it
come on now
oh Devon Williams
fun you don't even know what you would
just walked into son
come on you have no idea
oh Devon
I think he can go up here and just super
chatting
like it's nothing you know the toll it's
gonna take on my body Dawn because what
you just did
garov we will get to you I know we will
get to you
but my boy Devon over here
we grew up together
I gotta give this to you Devon this one
right here this one's for you I'm gonna
get to 42. all right just for you and
it's not gonna go behind the piano this
time
come on
let's do this
watch me get three
that's 20 that's 20.
30.
all right that's 37.
that ain't that ain't bad that's that's
five off from the world record Devon we
almost beat the world record
oh but alas I got another
chance I got another opportunity because
garav Diaries
you got me with that super chat
um you said you're new to 3D
um by copying stuff from the internet
will that count as Improvement or am I
just wasting my time please bear with me
ah yes great question great great
question so
you're talking about
following tutorials and like you know
putting that out as like your art or
recreating something and saying oh it's
my art
let me tell you what this is what I did
for years you know why I did it because
it was fun it was very very fun I wasn't
thinking about that when I was younger
and I was just you know like I have uh
you know my art book
and you know let me show you let me show
you I'll show you what I mean
so when I was a kid
you know I drawing was my jam right and
like also martial arts right so I would
find images of my favorite martial
artists online and I would draw them so
here's Bruce Lee
very simple and then there's this game
called jet Lee's rise to honor and I was
like let me draw the box art so this is
from that right
so
I was I was doing what you're talking
about you know I was doing exactly what
you're talking about here's more
you know
it's just
box art DVD covers
video game covers you know I think this
was Ratchet and Clank three or something
and I would you know just pull images
from online and draw them I would I
would copy them right
and that was so much fun for me and I
wouldn't have
improved my art skills if I didn't do
that
now there's a difference between like
you doing that and say look what I came
up with look what I made and it's like
well technically
it's like it's more of like a practice
thing right it's not it's not like I'm
not like selling these pieces of art you
know because this is someone else's
photo this is someone else's photo that
I drew
um now until you're coming up with like
your own original stuff you know like
taking pictures of your friends and
drawing your friends like yours
I would do these like blind contour
drawings and shade them really nicely
like
the whole point is you follow tutorials
to learn and grow your skills and grow
your craft but then you eventually you
want to start doing your own stuff your
own custom stuff
um you know so I don't know all these
you know some of these are definitely
copies of stuff of course
right that's just right up right out uh
of the movie I think it's still frame of
the movie
um some of these you know this is like a
drawing of my dad that I did
right
so that one is kind of along the same
vein of
uh
you know it's it's along the same vein
of take your own photos make Recreations
of your own photos it's the same thing
with drawing it's the same thing with 3D
so
follow those tutorials do your
Recreations have fun with it do what's
fun that's gonna push you further
um but then start start coming up with
your own ideas too at the same time you
do them in tandem then you can really be
proud of that original idea that you
came out with it's super fun
um
very good question
and I think I got to do some hacky sack
for you for that
um so we're trying to be 41 right now
16 17 18 20.
30 32 334 35.
almost saved it almost saved it 35
that's not bad
oh
it's freaking fun
oh so
okay
um block Warriors that you hope to make
it into the competition you put your
render into the editing software change
the frame rate and resolution be correct
yes good job
good job good job good job
amazing
let's get back
to the art shall we
do that thing almost in the paper
shredder
oh
it's a close one
so I'm stuck trying to figure out this
dang tile situation
like
why does it have to be so difficult
shouldn't box just have it be like all
normal
[Music]
you know what I could probably do
is
just mess with it here
set it to cubic
and
why does it look like that why does it
not
like it looks correct here right
[Music]
and tile it 10 times
see what this does
the hardest part is just like trying to
see what the heck is going on here I
can't see the vertical lines I can only
see the
tourism
oh
yo I bet you're right Soto
genius
oh
thank you Soto
but it's weird because I think
displacement doesn't work
um let's
let's see let's see let's see let's see
let's go octane
glossy
and we need to set our
index to one
so we can see this is like fully chromed
out
at this point
and we're not seeing the car so let me
take the normal map down to zero take
the normal map away and I'm going to
take the displacement map
away
and the roughness looks like it's also
making it difficult to see
foreign
let's just take the roughness out
and it's just blurry all right so now
it's like where's my car
right so we're trying to get back
to that point of like
here we go
we're just trying to return to normal
here
and I'm not seeing
the car here's what I'm gonna do let's
let's grab this uh material we set up
before
pop it on here
okay it's probably acting this way
because
it's bending we're like bending
uh
a little bit
wow
that's so weird
right so like technically we can see the
car but it's like
way wigged out because of
the angled tunnel so I think what we'll
do
is
try and just go off of this flat wall
ing off a flat wall is gonna be a lot
easier
what the heck
I think it has to do with like
the weird the weird UVS on this thing if
I delete this
yeah it's like these weird UVs
[Music]
so it's like maybe we're just
we're making this overly complicated
[Music]
so I'll just try it with a cube
we'll go inside this Cube
[Music]
and let's get rid of the
depth of field
it's definitely weird like that's not
I think it's because we're seeing
reflections and Reflections and
Reflections
path tracing is going to give us the
abilities we're we're in a
glass box right now and I think this is
technically
correct
yeah I think this is technically correct
there is like a dark
a weird like dark thing I feel like
where's that coming from
I delete this
coming from
I think that's when you run out of
bounces because obviously you could
bounce yeah so if I go octane settings
and I set
let's see my jet clamp to one
I don't need 16k samples but we say
diffuse depth
if we take it to two
yeah let's go lower it
and it was at 16 before and if we take
it up to 32 yeah you're right Soto
amazing amazing amazing amazing
okay
so we'll hop in here
and we're moving along cool cool cool
let's mess with that material again okay
so dirty ceramic wall let's open it up
and see what we can start messing with
the
[Applause]
the normal let's bring back the normal
to one
ah yes it's because we need to project
it properly now so I'm gonna do what we
did last time just inside
it's been a minute since I used this I
remember running into an issue let's
just let's just move forward and run
into the issue together
do it as it happens
so we have projection I need the
transform back
boom all right
a projection will set to box
and I'll refresh this
and it looks like it's not
boss because I'm still in this camera
control shift Z will undo camera moves
there we go
and I think I'm going to make the cube
editable
all right so it looks proper on that
side
but for whatever reason doesn't look
proper on the other side so I'm gonna
take this back to just normal
so we can kind of see what's going on
yes we can see it's
it's very stretched
[Music]
foreign
this way and see how far we can get
let's tile it twice
okay
and we'll hop back in here
and see if we can get that reflection
back okay
so for that let's
um
take the roughness away
take the normal off
and see what we can see so if I set this
to one
that's yeah perfectly chromed out
three
four all right so it's a little bit more
reflective
let's bring the normal back in
that's going to break it up a lot even
without depth of field that's gonna
that's gonna break it up a whole bunch
so maybe we do let's try uh point one on
the normal
doesn't need to be that intense
I'm just gonna run to the region here
and let's try and bring our displacement
back in So if I take this height to 10
does it do anything
yes
it does and we lose our
car
back there so maybe I set it to one
and we lose it it's because it's
breaking up the the surface of it and
it's bouncing the light around we just
lose the uh we lose the reflection
entirely if I set this to
one to make it Chrome
yeah we still we still can't even see
the car it's crazy
set this to zero
and we get our car back
so it looks like displacement
is probably not what we're looking for
here
which is fine that's fine
now we can bring this roughness back in
and of course that's going to mess
everything up
and it looks like the roughness
why is the roughness
detached from
[Music]
there we go
I'm gonna try displacement again because
I think
the projection messed up the
displacement
yeah even the smallest amount still
throws it off so I'm gonna go without it
let's try and get our roughness back in
[Music]
we take the brightness to zero that just
turns it away completely
bring it up a touch
[Music]
maybe we take the contrast up a lot
foreign
we can hopefully solo this right click
solo the node
[Music]
we'll see what that looks like
we just chilled out a little bit bring
the brightness down
and let's take this index back up to
like five
[Music]
so we get a little bit of the the color
in there as well from the tiles
and the ambient occlusion I want to
bring this all the way up so I believe
we control that through the gamma
[Music]
we go eight
doesn't really do much versus one
too much either
maybe it's a power thing
yes
let's go ahead and solo this
yeah I want those to be really dark
in there that's going through multiply
so I want to get this as dark as
possible
[Music]
oh
and we can take this we can add a
gradient
to it
ingredient and we can crunch it
down
it'll solo the gradient
get those black levels real nice
sweet and hopefully that should be a
little bit better
and bring out the grunginess in this
which it looks like it's doing
[Music]
awesome
okay
so it's too bright
for me
um
let's bring the motion puller back in
and see what that looks like
laughs
it looks like we're losing our car again
when the motion blur kicks back in
so let's go to our car
let's give it an octane
tag or visibility uh for motion blur
let's try and change these I I don't
think this is the issue though
because I think our test we can always
test with this just glossy material
and I'm gonna go ahead and make sure
that my keyframes are not like
starting from stopped and slowing slowly
building speed I want to set these both
to linear
all right so the motion blur is Just
Happening immediately
foreign
looks like the motion blur is happening
on the car which it shouldn't be
the background that should be blurry the
car should be in focus
hmm
[Music]
that's the tricky one let's take the
cube so we can see what we're doing
instead of the X-ray
and I'm gonna go unlit so I think uh n c
we'll do that yeah
thank you
[Music]
yep yep that looks like it's working
properly
um
so
um it looks like we had a super chat
here
I don't want to miss it Vladimir yes
I could use a hacky sack break right now
we're in troubleshooting mode we're in
deep troubleshooting mode
right now
but it'll be good to move the body a
little bit so you hit me with a with a
super chat that means we're doing some
hacky sack
um but let's read it first so thank you
for starting this and giving me the
structure and motivation to get all of
uh to get into all this hack exact time
breaks are good for the brain dude it's
like you read my mind absolutely
absolutely
um dude yeah you're welcome I guess I
don't know I do it because it's fun and
like you guys
have have put together such a freaking
awesome uh
thing I guess you know it's like you
guys come to the table with with your
best every time we do these challenges
and the montages are so much fun to
watch they're so much fun to make
so it's kind of a no-brainer at this
point
um I'm just glad it's a win-win-win for
all of us right so hack exact time let's
see if we can be 41 that is still the
world record
let's Beat It
oh man
11.
it's 11. definitely not world record
quality but you know what it's the fact
that we try this is the best part
gotta go for it every time thank you
Vladimir
much appreciated guys we're gonna go for
another 20 minutes here and then
I gotta go to kickball
so let's see what we can do let's see if
we can't clean this up I know I'm not
gonna be able to finish this thing but
you know it is what it is
any questions you guys have
let me let me answer them I'm here to
help you guys get through the finish
line
um
inverting the tunnel normals that's a
good idea I'm down for that
because right now
yep
you are is gonna flip it
so that might actually help us
[Music]
thank you
I'm going to solve the motion blur
problem later
because right now we're focused on
trying to get the look right and it's
too bright so I'm gonna
get a little bit of vignette in here
already that looks better
and let's go to our light
hmm
we have car lights
on the car itself
let's mess with those let's see what
those are up to
cool and then
let's try and give it a little bit of
instead of a strip of light like we're
doing here let's actually do
let's set up an IES light
okay we'll bring this up
and I want to choose IES okay light
settings
[Music]
um
surface brightness off
we'll go into the distribution and we're
going to load an IES light and IES is
just like a light profile like shape I'm
gonna load that in
and I think we got to make the light
pretty darn small
you see there
see that shape that light shape there
yikes
pretty sweet so we can just choose one
we like
maybe that's not the one you know maybe
we're trying to go for this like star
shape or something
nah I'm looking for like a direct like a
floodlight Spotlight situation I think
that totally works
um and we can set some up for the car
headlights as well but we'll do our our
tunnel lights
right up here
[Music]
and let's go ahead and set the
temperature to like uh
[Music]
3200 so it's a little bit more on the
warm side
and
take the intensity
up a bit maybe 400 or something works
for me maybe 8 000. those LEDs going
that led light and I'm gonna do the same
thing with like a cloner I'm gonna hold
alt pop it in the cloner and we just
want a linear clone and we'll do that
over the X
[Music]
yep every 400 centimeters and we'll do
that 20 times maybe we'll take that to
800.
right so they're going to be doing their
thing all the way to the end of that
tunnel we got lights to the end of the
tunnel right
[Music]
so now when we hop in and we look at our
scene
we're starting to get
something that looks kind of good kind
of good I'll say kind of good
um we can take since we're in Aces
if we push the exposure nothing will
truly blow out it is looking a little
washed out and I think that just comes
from the
Ultra Uber reflective tile that we're
working with
[Music]
foreign
thing you could probably do is
get it to
let's see
[Music]
because we need it to be reflective in
order to see uh the car right but we're
really seeing the car now I like that
the lights come let's go 600.
and it just needs some contrast
is all because if our two
pop out of the camera
look at our scene
right we can see it's very dark in here
the Shadows are actually very dark
we're kind of losing that in the wall
itself
[Music]
foreign
that looks super cool that looks awesome
I love it
I'll definitely get a test render going
after this before we call it
um any questions you guys have please
drop them here in the chat I'm gonna be
looking oh Christopher Kessler we got a
little hacky sack session in store
um let me get through a couple more
minutes of this here and we'll get back
to you and I'll answer you guys
questions in the last 10 minutes here on
the live stream
um I'm gonna set up a render and set up
a render real quick
so we can take the index to maybe three
foreign
that's nice okay so we still see it
doesn't have to be as reflective 1.3
all right so we're seeing more wall now
it's darker
um
I like that that's a good
good vibe there we can do
um let's take the exposure up
[Music]
oh
I'm even gonna hide this box
um
from The View here let's see this is our
true tunnel
the hide it from the viewport so it's a
little easier to maneuver
um
maybe if we take the
lights bring them a little lower Maybe
yeah
and I think we need a little bit more
roughness
going on here so let's go ahead and solo
this
we'll take the brightness up to one
and
yikes
0.7 let's try point six
point seven
and then I'll give this a
gradient because I want to make the
black like a dark gray
octane gradient pipe that in there
so this
and then the black will become like a
dark gray so it's still a little rough
and of course we gotta unsolo
unless we just redo this
let load yeah
so there's a few things I don't like
about this right now it's like the
headlights aren't bright enough those
really need to pop
so I feel like
I can come up into here
take the emission
and we can
just render this only
I just take this to like Max
it's barely changing it's crazy
I think it has to do with my texture
properties here
[Music]
lots of back and forth
trying to get the the right values and
this is only one material we're working
with we still have like other materials
to test out but I think once we really
figure out the balance of things it'll
uh it'll start to feel right
I think they're normal
up a little bit more that blurs things
out a bit
really works that detail in there
foreign
such a fine balance here
I'm gonna give this a test render I'm
gonna throw on the motion blur
and just let this render while I'm at
kickball
um let's do
let's enable that
and see what happens I think this one's
definitely gonna be sample hungry
I'll throw 1500 at it
um let's do a bit of
denoising
enable that
I'll set it to 0.5 because I like a
little bit of that green in there
um
and let's double check
set up our render settings
to
uh
uh all right so octane render let's use
the denoise beauty pass
let us do an exr sequence
and let's get this going
into the art
render output
let's call this tunnel
[Music]
sweet I think we're pretty much good to
export this bad boy all frames 192. this
one's definitely be
render hungry
um I don't know if I'll make it to 192
by the time I get back but 1920x810 is
good as a test
and
I'm gonna hit render on this thing
[Music]
see what happens sweet
uh guys thank you thank you I'm gonna
take like five minutes here
um because we really do gotta bounce
but I'm gonna take five minutes here to
thank everybody we got Christopher
Kessler
um
Jesus Christ's name be healed please
check a color blind test
colorblind tests it's because of that I
couldn't be a fighter pilot I wanted to
be a fighter pilot
but they were like nah you colorblind
you ain't gonna you ain't doing nothing
I was like man I might as well
do VFX or something
[Music]
um I feel like that was every little
kid's dream
but I owe you some hacky sack let's see
if we can beat 41. this is like the last
chance
truly
truly seems like oh no we got Jack Peach
giving me one more one more extra life
Jack can I have the flash running as my
subject
um it's more of a vehicle challenge
so that's a stretch I'd say
the tough one man that's a tough one
yeah I don't know
but you gave me you gave me a second
life with the hacky sack so we got two
lives here let's see if we can be 41 in
a little time we got left
foreign
20.
10.
that's 40.
seven eight all right that's 50.
55 yes
we did it right at the end there amazing
um
heck yeah Christopher Christopher
Kessler that one's for you appreciated
man
really good stuff
um Jack Peach well we'll get yours as
the final one we'll close it out with
some hacky sack right at the end okay
um but let's answer any questions
lightning around
uh
how tuts asks when you launched your
first challenge did you ever imagine it
would go this big
thanks for helping unite the community I
had no idea I was just trying to make a
cool video like that's really that's
really it at the end of the day I was I
was having a good time trying to
challenge myself and uh yeah it really
it popped off amazing it's really helped
me do this uh as a as a career so
thank you guys
is it's amazing it really is amazing
um
let's see
so we have
you have two main vehicles in your scene
can I animate the first one going away
from the scene and have the other one
come right after the first one leaves
yeah I mean that'd be pretty cool
in general it's like you know I always
imagine it as
as one vehicle but if you do something
cool with two vehicles that's cool too
the cool thing is like I can't think of
every option you know like we try and
build the rules in the FAQs off of what
we can just imagine but there's so much
stuff that you guys do beyond what we
imagine like if it's cool go for it as
long as it kind of generally follows the
rules you guys are gonna have a good
time
um how many do you estimate
this time around I know it was 3600 last
time I've had to see what this is going
to look like yeah me too right now we're
on track for for getting there you know
3600 I think is very possible in the
time that we've been streaming we've had
uh wow almost 20 people
submit uh Javier Draven K Zella Alex
Parkin unreal matter Christopher Chase
Marson
bonus
Dan horstman Leong by
shout outs to you guys
um earlier we had Dennis spap killer R
Florham do you Aaron easel Ryan Smith
Benjamin do we John Miele and just
just now go cool CJ
uh congratulations for submitting guys
you deserve a day off for sure enjoy
your weekend I wish I could uh could
join you guys and hang out for a little
bit longer but truly we do need to
bounce and play some kickball
I'll close it out with them one last
round of hacky sack for our boy Jack
Peach thank you guys for the support
thank you for the love
um where did it go
oh
I'll catch you guys later thank you so
much uh stay passionate stay creative
let's keep learning let's keep growing
together peace out guys
hang on man
12 that ain't good that ain't good
that's yup you got it
[Music]
tip tip